Доброго дня шановні колеги вітаємо вас
на локації підтримують дитину підтримка
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами в
освітньому процесі
наша локація розрахована на дві години
протягом цих двох годин ми спробуємо
дуже оперативно висвітлити всі ці теми
які стосуються освіти особливості дітей
з особливими освітніми потребами в цьому
навчальному році
Нагадую що в нас іде пряма трансляція
нашої локації на сторінці Facebook
Міністерства освіти і науки України а
також буде запис зазначеної локації які
будуть також викладені на офіційних
сторінках Міністерства освіти і науки
України тому дуже прошу вас
дотримуватися правил етикету
онлайн-нарад тобто обов'язково тримати
вимкненим звук
вимкнути мікро тримати ввімкненим звук
але вимкнути мікрофони дуже прошу
Протягом всієї наради
тримати їх вимкненими і стежити за тим
щоб не було зайвих звуків для того щоб
не заважати нашим колегам
включатися і слухати нашу зустріч також
Нагадую що є пряма трансляція тому
камери за можливістю прошу тримати
включеними і е-е ну розумієте що йде
трансляція також нагадую про правила
безпеки у випадку якщо ви почуєте
сигнали повітряної тривоги ми просимо
вас не ігнорувати ці сигнали а
переміщатися в обов'язкововище І
нагадуємо що ще раз Що запис буде
доступний і ви зможете його подивитися в
зручний для вас час в першу чергу
давайте про свою безпеку і
прислухатися до сигналів повітряної
тривоги
наразі починаємо нашу
локацію з хвилини мовчання в пам'ять
загиблих у війні проти Росії тому прошу
вас на хвилину
вшанувати пам'ять наших героїв
запрошую до слова першого нашого
виступаючого це наш
дуже великий друг нашої освіти осіб з
особливими освітнього потребуми людина
яка приділяє дуже велику увагу захисту
прав дітей а також наданню можливості
всім дітям в Україні навчатися ця людина
Ви всі дуже гарно знаєте бо ця людина не
просто одноразово допомагала чи звертала
увагу це людина яку асистемно підтримує
освіту освіту особливо освітнього
потребу дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами спеціальні заклади освіти і
реально дбає про їх не тільки безпеку А
про те щоби наші діти мали можливість
навчатися де вони не були і як би не
складалися обставини запрошую до слова
Павла Миколайовича Сушко народного
депутата України
Доброго дня шановні колеги радий вас
всіх вітати
дійсно тут зібралися люди які
які присвятили все своє життя в сфері
дітей і не просто дітей а особливо дітей
діти з особливими освітніми потребами і
це дуже важка праця Я дуже це добре знаю
і війна на жаль виразно всі ці проблеми
які були в цій сфері багато-багато років
до початку війни я очолював тимчасово
слідчої комісії якраз яка була
направлена на захист дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами і Нам вдалося
спільними зусиллями з вашої підтримкою
також
змінити внести зміни Постанову
уряду щодо реформи деістолізації Таким
чином ми разом з вами
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами
зараз звичайно цей захист діти
потребують ще більшого захисту яким буде
навчання дітей наших дітей які пережили
війну бачили війну в умовах війни
на дистанційному навчанні за кордоном це
все вам представить
здійснити дати свою пропозицію
напрацювання із цим працювати
весь цей час
дуже вдячний вам що ви продовжити
займатися нашими дітьми
Не дивлячись на обстріли на війну
знаходитись перед з дітьми знаходиться
на своїй місцях та продовжити цю дозу
нещодавно ми прийняли Верховну Раду і
закон про створення державної служби
України у сфері дітей
де розмежували повноваження між державою
та
громадами і довели всіх ці в цьому
напрямку довели до кінця реформу
децентралізації і громада вже мають
створювати
службу у справах дітей чітка
відповідальність голів роман це все буде
допомагати безумовно дітям сьогодні
президент України вніс свої пропозиції
до цього закону незабаром ми
проголосуємо ці пропозиції з 1 січня
23-го року цей закон має вступити в дію
тому я вам бажаю успіхів у цьому закладі
успіхів на місцях
Разом до перемоги Слава Україні
Дуже дякуємо вам за виступи також дуже
дякуємо за вашу систему постійно
підтримку
Я не даю слово Віктору Васильовичу
салькового виконуючи обов'язки керівника
експертної групи з питань позашкільної
та інклюзивної освіти директора
дошкільної шкільної позашкільної освіти
з темою забезпечення освіти осіб з
особливими освітніми потребами В умовах
воєнного стану після
Дякую його Ольга Олександрівна за те що
ви мені надали слово я тут поруч
знаходжуся хочу сказати що ми
знаходимося у дуже чудовому місті це
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр
Голосіївського району міста Києва дефіс
передових інклюзивно-ресурсних центрів
Хоча я абсолютно розумію що нікого
окремо виділяти не буду всі на сценки
дуже чудові дуже гарно обладнані тому що
саме завдяки
вам ваші особисті участі у всіх і
кожного наш інклюзивно-ресурсний центр
стали е
об'єктом не лише краси Скажімо так і і
обладнання стали об'єктом фаховості
об'єктом професіоналізму і
сенками де збираються
ті люди які вболівають за наших дітей
які вболівають за спільну справу
перейдемо тоді до нашої теми шановні
друзі Я більше ніж переконаний що
більшість учасників секцій сьогодні
дивилися пряму трансляцію основної
локації слухали міністра слухали шановні
гостей проте
я хочу зараз вам
всім ще хто не бачив сказати хто чув
нагадати з приводу початку
2000 до 2003 навчального року
Існує чотири моделі повернення дітей до
навчання дуже складно що в цей процес
війна переміщення постійні постійні
загрози
ми перша освіта яка працює в умовах
військового часу і Ви перші педагоги які
є військовим
фактично військову тому що ви
знаходитеся на передовій освіті робота з
особливими дітьми вона потребує більших
навичок якраз під час саме військового
стану тож перейдемо до моделі
перша модель - це якщо дитина
знаходиться в межах України на безпечній
території
відповідно Вона може здобувати очну
форму навчання це однозмінна двозмінна
форма з урахуванням
місць в укриті і якщо прийнято рішення
відповідне військову цивільної
адміністрації це дистанційна форма
навчання це у закладах освіти де діти
навчаються за рішенням лица та
адміністрації навчального закладу
дистанційно визнання це сімейна домашня
форма навчання за рішенням чи вибором
батьків у визначених закладах освіти
змішана форма навчання це форма навчання
яка
і очна і з використанням технологій
інвестиційного навчання ну фактично
ви знаєте ці форми під час проїду і з
початком бойових дій таких
і відповідно четверта форма - це
екстернат
проходити в закладах освіти за рішенням
батьків для стандартну та сімейної форми
навчання діти та батьки можуть додатково
використовувати онлайн ресурси
насамперед всеукраїнської школи онлайн
де розміщені всі навчальні матеріали для
учнів 5-11 класів або відповідно до
мобільних застосок
друга модель - це якщо діти є внутрішньо
переміщеними
[музика]
особами в межах України Тут також
існує
5 таких самих Форм це точно дистанційна
сімейна змішана я не буду повторювати
хочу інше єдине щодо
очної форми навчання є нюанси щодо
зарахування і переведення заклад
наступна модель про це дитина діти які
знаходяться на тимчасово окупованих
територіях чи на території проведення
бойових тут
застосовується той форма навчання це
дистанційна або екстренат або дитина за
дистанційну форму це в закладах освіти
на підконтрольній території України
сімейна домашня форма навчання за
також за вибором батьків у визначених
закладах розташованих також на
підконтрольних
територій та
екстернат для подовження за українськими
програмами з наступним отриманням
українського документу про освіту
батьків або опікуни можуть подати заяву
про зарахування до будь-якого закладу
загальної середньої освіти небезпечну
територію України і отримати відповідно
допомогу глубили закладу можуть надати
органи управління освіти ти наявності
доступу до мережі Інтернет можна онлайн
вступити до будь-якої української
школи та продовжити навчання затриманням
відповідно документу про освіту
державного реєстру
і остання модель - це коли діти
знаходяться за кордоном Тут також
вони можуть як і
безпечних територіях також застосовувати
і очну форму навчання
[музика]
в закладах освіти країни де вони
перебувають або українські школах та
класах з використанням дистанційного
навчання або екстренати дистанційної
форми навчання сімейний Та екстерметр я
більш детально не буду зупинятися на
нюансах здобуття освіти за кожною формою
Відповідно ми розійшлоемо управління
освіти Ми
відповідні рекомендації презентації для
того щоб
більш простою мовою педагогам
пояснити яким чином і як можна засто
зробити ту чи іншу форму для в нашому
випадку для дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами а також для спеціальних за-
закладів освіти
відповідно до початку навчального року
ми сьогодні поговоримо з Ольгою
олександровою що
будуть відповідні Методичні рекомендації
з урахуванням уже застосування цих
чотирьох моделей миронічно не могли
надати
надати ті чи інші
рекомендації оскільки Ці моделі лише
лише
за розмову
тож перейдемо до основної теми
виступу щоб я хотів би сказати Можливо я
буду коротко Я краще потім надам слово
Ольги Олександровича Сьогодні ми дарує
наші звуки чи вона додасть Від чого є
щось допустив Я можливо
зосереджуюсь на основних меседжах
відповідно до того Які ви надаєте нам
запити і
і відповідно
те що ми чуємо і бачимо який виклик Ну
те що ми під час війни
завдяки вам Завдяки тому що що ви нас
чуєте слухаєте і нам підказуйте змінили
ту чи іншу нормативно-правову базу Ну
більше це стосувалося
інклюзивно-ресурсних центрів де ми
розширили
можливості для інклюзивно-ресурсних
центрів з урахуванням
військового стану бойових дій я ну не
буду зосереджуватися так більш детально
за обмеженим часом бо я хочу щоб ви
послухали інших скільки ми це детальніше
випишемо
в методичних рекомендаціях Ну і
відповідно більш детально ми будемо з
вами про це говорити уже з традиційних
наших онлайн-конференціях можемо з
кожною області можемо зв'язано областей
для того щоб більш детальніше вам
результати щодо застосування
законодавства щодо Скажімо так
збільшення вікового центру це щодо
штатних розписів є це там тоже
найближчим часом дуже сподіваються
будуть будуть зміни от щодо тих
постійних конференцій підвищення
кваліфікації по психологічній підтримці
учасників освітнього процесу Я дуже вам
вдячний що всі тут присутні і не
присутні ті хто нас дивляться на Ютубі
Міністерства освіти науки в нашому
партнером з юнісефіків отут поруч зі
мною знаходяться за допомогою підручника
ми будемо її надалі це проводити що
стосується міжнародних партнерів то ми
плануємо вже найближчим часом
осінню презентувати для
управлінців обласних департаментів
управління освіти такий спектр проектів
Ну скажімо так такий певний фестиваль
проектів Тобто ми хочемо вам
презентувати усі проекти які в інклюзії
спеціальній освіті ми ведемо з нашими
міжнародними партнерами для того щоб
більш детально розповісти можливості
кожного регіону взяти участь в
донорських проектах відповідно щодо
відновлення заходів освіти щодо
забезпечення це матеріалами щодо
забезпечення дітей
технологіями дистанційного навчання
тому
більш детальніше там огляд Олександра
скаже єдине що я хочу Ну скажімо так
зробити декілька оголошень і можливо і і
застележим
відповідно до вас всіх Запитів зараз
готуються зміни до державного стандарту
загальних середньої освіти тому ми дуже
сподіваємося щодо початку навчального
року вже
всі круги адами пройшли з центральним
органом виконавчої влади вже
направляються відповідно постанова
Кабінету Міністрів та затвердження
урядом і на кінець уже програми для
учнів ті прогавини які були в державному
стандарті вони будуть нівельовані і в
цьому плані Дуже дякуємо вам нам за
підказку щоб були такі поганим свої
відповідні зміни також хочу вам
повідомити приємну новину
що вчора експертну комісію спеціальний
педагогіки
інституту модернізації змісту освіти
було розглянуто і спалено 29 програм з
колекційної роботи це 8 для спеціальних
закладів освіти для всіх сполучених
опорному полового апарату одна для
закладів де діти з тяжкими порушеннями
мовленнями 8 для заходів для дітей з
порушенням слуху всім для дітей із
порушеннями
інтелектуального розвитку і дві для
дітей з порушеною зону і ти для дітей з
інтелектуальними труднощами легкого
ступені променів Я дуже сподіваюся що Ну
можливо вже сьогодні я не слідкував що
готувався до конференції ці всі гріховні
програми
будуть на сайті мон Слідкуйте і на сайті
тому організації змісту освіти тут
ми також начебто виконали свої обіцянки
я я бачу що
схвально глухаєте голову тому дуже Дякую
і вам за підказки і за роботу і зважаючи
на той доволі невеликий ресурс Ми
намагаємося
ці всі питання То гауни максимально
заповнити для того щоб вам легше було
працювати хочу окремо наголосити на
підтримці дітей особливо в статусних
дітей які бувають за кордоном друзі Їм
як ніколи зараз і тим групам дітей
спеціальних заклади освіти в основному
спеціальних закладах і дітей які з
батьками ви їх конкретно як ніколи
потрібно ваша підтримка
я займався цими процесами Особисто я
знаю фактично поіменну всіх дітей які
перебувають у складі груп за кордоном і
вони там знаходяться уже
деякі навіть більше ніж півроку вони
починають сумувати за Україну відповідно
сумувати за своїми друзями з якими
спілкувалися в закладі звичайно
дистанційне навчання
якій більшості українських дітей вже ну
відразу кажучи трошки набридло вже
повністю
формують батьки голосують тому
звертаюся особисто до керівників
закладів першочергово спеціальної освіти
звичайно До керівників закладів
загальної середньої освіти поділяти їм
особливу увагу з точки зору
психологічної підтримки те саме
звичайно стосується дітей з внутрішньо
переміщених
внутрішньо переміщення здебільшого
здобувають
ми будемо значить партнерами робити все
можливе і неможливо для того щоб дати
відповідні інструменти цієї
психологічної підтримки в тому числі
нашим хабом і закордоном будемо
намагатися врегулювати питання ротації
педагогічних працівників про це ми
ведемо
постійно розмову з органом управління
освіти і відповідно
з міністерством фінансів бо це не дешева
штука
тому На цьому я хочу акцентувати увагу
щодо підтримки ми розуміємо що уже є
деякі групи які повертаються Ну а
більшість звичайно зважаючи на цю
зашиську дурню що вони творить кожної
ночі дня
в тому числі і з гуртожитками і
закладами освіти в Україні в будь-якому
разі ще існує небезпека і ви це
прекрасно знаєте і незалежно де б то з
нас сьогодні не знаходився чи в Рівному
чи в Харкові чи на Франківщині чи в
Чернігівській області тому переходжу
саме до безпекових питань
Шановні колеги в закладах яких існують
я вас закликаю 20 раз подумати
тим як відкривати пансіонат
особливо це стосується пенсіонів тих
закладів де перебувають діти з глухотою
вчорашній прильот на Харків
ви знаєте всі читали це стосується інших
дітей які вночі перебуватимуть на цьому
в цьому пансіоні це персонал який має
забезпечити вночі
перехід на бомбосовища якщо це
бомбосховище існує
Я дуже прошу зважити це відповідальність
органів місцевого самоврядування це
відповідальність військово-цивільних
адміністрацій Ми прекрасно розуміємо
усвідомлюємо мотиви батьків які кажуть
так ми хотіли щоб діти перебували
пансіоні хотіти
і втратити Не дай Бог це абсолютно
різні речі
ми в методичних рекомендаціях то пишемо
свої застележення
можливо і реально в нинішній
складних військових військової ситуації
знайти інші методи
де цим дітям перебувати знаходити інші
рішення
існують дистанційні методи
та інші безпека дітей понад усе
що стосується саме дистанційного
навчання на цих так плавно перейшов
побутує думка в керівників закладів
можливо їх педагогів і всіх інших що
якщо надається освіта в дистанційній
формі по асистент вчителя для дитини тут
ні до чого
ця думка
крамольна і невірна
асистент вчителя забезпечує навчання
дітей з особливими освітнім потребами і
допомагаю вчителем ти здобутті освіти за
будь-якої форми запам'ятайте запишіть за
будь-якою формою якщо якщо тут
стосується питань фінансових Так можливо
недостат часу вентів всі інші ми готові
це в кожному окремому випадку розглядати
але не треба плутати освітній процес і
фінансові питання це речі тотожні але
вони абсолютно інші
жодної мільйонів чи десятків мільйонів
будь-якій валюті не кошти освічена
людина це безцінний капітал А щоб
здобути освіту особливо нашим дітям
треба докласти зусиль це ще більш
безцінне Це ваша праця це ваше навчання
це ваше само мотивація
антивигорання і все інше що потребує
дуже складних зусиль внутрішню а також
зовні от саме за це за ці зусилля за
безцінний капітал це український
педагоги які працюють з українськими Я
хочу вам сьогодні подякувати
я тоді з вашого дозволу передам слово
сьогодні олександрівні
яка можливо додасть те що я не дав
можливо а я ще раз Хочу вам подякувати
Хай кожному і всіх вас збережемо
та й буде ми
Хай закінчиться ця клята війна для того
щоб ми є переконсував наступну серпневу
конференцію зібралися очно у Великому
залі не могли би привітатися потиснути
один одного року хтось поцілуватися хто
кого багато не бачив
бо ми переможемо обов'язково переможемо
Слава Україні і слава українським
педагогам
буквально декілька слів ви знаєте що
Протягом цього періоду війни ми вносили
зміни до деяких установ в першу чергу
прошу вас хто ще не ознайомився
подивитися зі змінами які були внесені в
порядок організації інклюзивного
навчання в закладах загальної середньої
освіти це є дуже важливим тому що там є
зміни пов'язані саме з військовим станом
і з особливим періодом Я хочу звернути
вашу увагу на кількість дітей яка може
бути яка може бути
в одному класі для дітей з дітей з
особливими потребами в одному
інклюзивному класі Також я прошу
звернути вашу увагу що ми ще всередині
липня провели вебінар ви можете із ним
познайомитися на сторінці
сторінці Міністерства освіти і науки
України там є запис цього вебінару або
якщо треба буде щоб легше шукати ви
можете
сторінці на сторінці моїх колег він є те
що розповсюджений для того щоб його було
легше знайти який був присвячений
питанням створення індивідуальної
програми розвитку для дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами які навчаються в
інклюзивних класах заходів загальної
середньої освіти Я думаю що цей семінар
вам буде вебінар було вам буде корисним
бо ми спробували там розглянути протягом
години яким чином скласти індивідуальну
програму що в ній обов'язково має бути
зазначено які питання не треба зазначати
А як на яких обов'язково зосередити
увагу і як це зробити як створити таку
програму як я її користуватися тому я
раджу не познайомилися Ще з цим
семінаром приєднатися до нього і
подивитися бо там будуть відповіді на
ваші певні питання
при цьому також раджу вам подивитися
зміни які були внесені в положення Про
організацію інклюзивне навчання в
закладах дошкільної освіти ці зміни
також стосуються періоду період
військових дій для того щоб забезпечити
е-е освіту дітей з особливими потребами
в інтерв'ю місцях де люди з дитиною
безпосередньо зараз знаходиться
крім цього
зазначу що найближчим часом будуть
внесені зміни в положення про
спеціальної школи і положення про
навчально-реабілітаційний центр який ми
спробуємо
забезпечити максимальне долучення
закладів в закладів спеціальної освіти
до
можливості надати послуги для дітей які
навчаються на інклюзивному навчанні для
того щоб максимально створити будь-які
можливості максимально створити умови
для того щоб кожна дитина в Україні
змогла і Та яка перебуває зараз змушена
перебувати зараз за кордоном змогла
отримати освіту яка їй потрібна і змогла
отримати відповідні освітні послуги
також зазначу що крім цього були внесені
зміни в положення про
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр 185 постанова
ми зможете з цими по цими змінами
познайомитися Якщо коротко То там
розширено завдання в центрі нада
додаткові гарантії особи з особливими
освітнього потребами які вимушені
змінити місце проживання чи перебування
вони передбачають скорочені терміни для
того щоб пройти комплексу
психолого-педагогічну оцінку можливість
подавати документи не лише батькам а й
тим особам які супроводжують таких дітей
на випадок якщо вони переїхали і немає
ще не призначено така особа або вони це
перебувають у інших своїх родичів
передбачені можливості для подання заяв
отримання консультації із фахівцями це
висновки в такому чи психолого-педичну
оцінку розвитку зернових умов
дозволено використання
застосунку дія коли вони можуть
безпосередньо надавати
для того щоб поліпшити ситуацію для тих
людей які були змушені швидко поїхати зі
своїх домівок і втратили документи
зменшення термін проведення комплексної
оцінки для дітей які тимчасово змінили
місце проживання розширені можливості
категорії повторну комплексну оцінки
розвитку дітей з метою проведення
моніторингу все те про що питали щодо
того про дітей які приходять з рівня на
рівень але й крім цього цей ще також
письмо про зміни до спеціальних шкіл Ми
також відносимо певні корективи які ви
просили на місцях з вашого досвіду якщо
наприклад дитина залишилася над
тимчасово окупованій території і немає
можливості виїхати куди важливий
ресурсного центру як тоді забезпечити і
щодо дітей які знаходяться за кордоном
але теж приходять з лінії дорівнює це
буде зазначено в новому змінах до
тут рядом постанови які будуть
найбільшим часом я раджу вам звертати
увагу на сайті Міністерства освіти і
науки ми ці зміни передаємо на найближчі
дні до Кабінету Міністрів України будемо
мати людей коротший час їх приймуть
прошу вас слідкувати за нашими
сторінками в Міністерства освіти на
офіційному сторінками мистецтва
російської науки України в
офіційним сайтом Facebook сторінка на
той же час Як тільки ви оці зміни будуть
включені дії ми обов'язково повинні в
наших груп Viber групах і
ресурсний центр підтримки інклюзивної
освіти і обов'язково обласних
департаментів освіти областей тому ви не
залишитеся своєю інформацією але все ж
таки я вас прошу час від часу слідкувати
за цими нашими офіційними джерелами для
того щоб бути в курсі так само хочу
зосередити вашу увагу на тому що
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр що ми змінили
враховуючи можливість
появи дітей яких будуть психологічні
травми наслідок перебування в
на території бойових дій або внаслідок
взагалі різних причин психологічних
грамотності і метою Ми з цією метою ми
розширили
пані Ольга Я вибачаюсь у вас виникнення
мікрофон дякую дякую
Пробачте напевно Дякую дуже напевно
зупинилися на тому місці в нас просто
постійно ще доєднуються люди і тому воно
і не відбувається Отже я не маю надію що
мене почули коли я закликала звертати
увагу на наші офіційні джерела для того
щоб мати можливість познайомитися з тими
інформацією оперативно що ми надсилаємо
і крім того Я ще звернув увагу
методичні рекомендації для початку
навчального року а також будуть ще
окремий лист які будуть стосуватися
асистента учня дитини так як ми знаємо
що це питання також викликало викликало
вас певні
мало певні до вас мало певні у вас
питання викликали це спробувала дуже
Коротко розповісти про ті всі дії які
зараз
на часі які були реалізовані для того
щоб забезпечити освіту сьогоднішніми
потребами і надаю наступне слово пані
Ірині Калініченко кандидат у
педагогічних наук завідуючий кафедри
педагогічної майстерності та інклюзивної
освіти Полтавської академії неперервної
освіти імені
стоградського яка виступить з теми
орієнтація діяльності
інклюзивно-ресурсних центрів бо є в
умовах воєнного стану
пані Ірина Я вас прошу до слова
Доброго дня Скажіть будь ласка чи ви
чуєте Бачите чи бачите презентацію
побачимо вас бачимо презентацію надаємо
вам слово дякую пані Оля Отже я знаєте
довго думала про що говорити із
керівниками ресурсних центрів з
підтримки інклюзивної освіти директорами
ірц фахівцями і це тому що починаючи із
ну я точно пам'ятаю але мабуть в березні
місяці ми вже працюємо ми вже є тими
воїнами педагогами як сказав Віктор
Васильович Ми мабуть воїни ірц які
збираємося
обговорюємо і мабуть змінюємо орієнтирим
чому змінюємо орієнтири тому що ми
маємо воєнний стан бо я не стан який
продовжений в Україні Як ви знаєте до 21
листопада 2022 року і тому ми шукаємо
нові орієнтири тому що
Колосальне навантаження про це треба
говорити Сьогодні яка є на ін була
ресурсний центр які теж відкрилися і
почали в очному форматі про це треба
говорити Одні із перших тижнів тоді
колишні заклади освіти не працювали і
тоді коли ще Ну по факту що навіть
думали да заклади освіти як відкриватися
які форми чи потрібно взагалі Скажіть
будь ласка чи в мене слайди вас
слухаються Я зараз наприклад Добре Отже
звичайно я думаю кожен ірц для себе
вибирав ті орієнтири і я думаю що вони
нас будуть дуже схожими і перший
орієнтир про який говорив Віктор
Васильович і Пані Ольга Олександрівна це
ми орієнтуємося на послуги і супровід
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами
осіб Якщо бути точним які змінили своє
місце проживання Звичайно це дуже часто
буває складно і ми перевантажені нашими
дітьми але ви знаєте я розглядаю це як
просто наши внесок перемогу в спільній і
дуже часто і на території Полтавської
області Саме це були тими першими людьми
які зустріли підтримали І взагалі
збудували чомусь мережу таких соціальних
контактів і для дитини інколи навіть для
всієї сім'ї звичайно ми орієнтуємося на
супровід і послуги тих дітей які мають
особливі освітні потреби можливо не
отримують такої допомоги такого
супроводу і ми знаємо що багато батьків
В умовах воєнного стану ті які навіть і
не хотіли звертатися до ірц Вони почали
звертатися вони зрозуміли що це єдина
установа яка відкрита це теж правда і
тут питання як зорієнтувати як всім
надати оцю підтримку і групові
консультації і як кожному приділити
увагу звичайно ми маємо такий орієнтирів
про це Олександр вона вже говорила що в
нас є і будучи діти які мають освітні
потреби які мають прояви наслідків
психологічної травми Я ще про це теж
буду говорити детально ми не є
клінічному якимось призовому психологом
не є психотерапевтами але ми є тими
людьми які можуть надати першу психологі
допомогою які можуть надати рекомендації
педагогу як забезпечити оце базове
ставлення до дитини дитині в школі не
потрібен щоб кожен педагог був
психологом йому потрібно Довіра йому
потрібна підтримка і ми про це можемо
говорити на сьогодні орієнтуємося на
створення безпечного простору
інклюзивно-ресурсного центру Я вкладаю
все поняття не лише укриття я теж буду
про це говорити і той орієнтир який дуже
часто Ми забуваємо це орієнтир Турбота
про себе і підтримка інших є теж буду
про це говорити те що говорила вона
Олександрівна ми маємо дійсно нові
постанови які діють в умовах воєнного
стану і постанова 483 яка стосується
організації інклюзивного навчання в здо
така постанова яку ми керуємося зміна
діяльності додаткових класів завданнях
інклюзивного ресурсних центрів це той
лист Міністерство освіти який вийшов 13
червня 2022 року теж Всі з ним знайомі
щодо забезпечення освіти осіб з
особливими о потребами і дуже коротко я
анонсую той проєкт постанови Кабінету
Міністрів про внесення змін до деяких
установ Кабінету Міністрів України але
виключно те що стосується змін в умовах
воєнного стану тому що я вважаю що ця
постанова нам дуже-дуже необхідна і ми
будемо чекати і затвердження чи
додаткові завдання які ми з вами вже
виконуємо да Вони теж стосуються
проведення додаткових комплексних оцінок
і додаткового супроводу для тих дітей
які вимушені і я знаєте оце слово завжди
підкреслюють вони вимушені вони вимушені
приїхати до нас а мабуть Ми вимушені все
ж таки надати оцю підтримку допомогу
якщо ми українці якщо ми хочемо
підтримати хоча дійсно перевантаження
маємо своїх дітей такі діти які будуть
зараховані бо вже зараховані в
інклюзивні класи групи закладів освіти і
не отримують додаткові
психолого-педагогічних
корекційно-розвиткових послуг за місце
навчання це та інформація батькам про те
які є заклади освіти і знаєте от я
нещодавно познайоми тим що одним із
факторів стресу стійкості для дитини є
соціальні контакти і ми розуміємо що
якщо дитина яка переїхала яка вимушена
змінила місце проживання воно втрачає
стару мережу соціальних контактів і дуже
часто директор фахівець це він будує цю
нову мережу разом із батьками дитини і є
оцей такою підтримкою ми надаємо
підтримку навіть не розуміючи що той час
виконує одне завдання як це І це надання
допомоги тим дітям які звинувачують
освіту з використанням технології
дистанційного навчання і не отримують
корекційно-розвиткових послуг внаслідок
особливостей психофізичного розвитку те
що говорила теж Ольга Олександрівна про
подання заяви і коли ми можемо приймати
документи копію документів ми вже
побачили що це надзвичайно крутим це як
мінімум зменшує оту стресову напругу яка
є у тих батьків які дійсно переїжджали і
точно не думали брати чи не брати
висновок той самий таку комплексну
оцінку Чи брати якісь документи це були
різні умови тому копі таких моментів Це
добре Це добре що це нормативно
закріплено і ми маємо повне право це
робити або ті документи які ми можемо
такі люди можуть пред'явити і з
використанням мобільного застосунку дія
ми говоримо про те що комплексна оцінка
у період дії воєнного стану вона для тих
дітей які переїхали на тимчасове місце
проживання проводиться протягом тижня з
моменту подання або звернення заяви це
теж є своєрідний виклик і ті ірц які
мають багато дітей які Скажімо так
переїхали Да в їхньому місцевість з цим
складаються цим справляється і дуже
важливими про це говоримо щоб не
знизилося Якось я далі буду про це
говорити тому що і як це підняло планку
усій Україні і як це довіряють і знаючи
якщо звертаються як це навіть В умовах
воєнного стану то ця комплексна оцінка
вона буде якісною вона не буде зроблена
поспіхом в період дії воєнного стану
комплексна оцінка з підготовки
відповідного висно проводиться протягом
5 робочих днів і власне те про що я
говорила що комплексна оцінка
залишається
комплексним вивченням дитини ми говоримо
про те що ми не тільки обстежень дитину
на основі там певних методик і тих
документів які ми маємо в приміщеннях
інклюзивно-ресурсного центру але для тих
здобувачів освіти обов'язково які
приходять на комплексну оцінку з
батьками не забуваємо що ми проводимо із
спостереження і додатково збираємо
інформацію і за місцем навчання дитини
якщо це можливо за місцем і проживання
перебування в тому числі
тимчасове перебування цієї дитини і
звичайно для цього якщо є заява заявка
то інклюзивно-ресурсний центр фахівці
можуть виїжджати на місце навчання особи
з особливими освітніми потребами або на
місце її проживання чи перебування в
тому числі тимчасово це перебування і я
знаю такий випадок я не буду зараз
говорити де це було але саме за рахунок
того що приїхали
офіційно-ресурсного центру за заявою
змінилося це місце перебування дитини
яке не відповідало ніяким
санітаногенічним нормам і так нема таких
умовах в наші діти не повинні жити тому
інколи навіть Через такі виїзди ми
можемо дійсно повпливати щось змінити в
житті цієї дитини це теж є важливо А те
що його теж Ольга Олександрівна що за
результатами конкурсної оцінки ми тепер
маємо звертати уваги на тих дітей і
надавати рекомендації педагогам те як
організовувати освітній процес і навіть
може настільки організовувати А як
підтримати Да в освітньому процесі дітей
які зазнали психологічної травми ми
директорами як це будемо про це говорити
як тут правильно визначати цю категорію
як не давати ці освітні труднощі всім
хто буде сьогодні в
проявляти да Скажімо так певно
нестандартну поведінку чи певні емоції
це є теж дуже важливо тому що можливо
як офіційні рецепти психологів як це
такого великого досвіду да як працювати
з такими дітьми в умовах війни але ми
повинні бачити що якщо це дитина яка
дійсно потребує уваги з боку вчителів
потребує підтримки і їх треба допомогти
тому будемо виставляти ці освітні
труднощами будемо говорити про певний
рівень підтримки які має бути для таких
дітей коли ми видаємо висновок
інклюзивно-ресурсного центру для
внутрішніх переміщених дітей і для дітей
Зоопарк це є можливість організувати
інклюзивне навчання тобто дитина
зараховується в інклюзивну групу клас
складається індивідуальну програму
розвитку надається
психолого-педагогічний корекційний
розвиткові послуги згідно з тим згідно
підтримки який був визначений така
дитина з нашим висновком зараховується
до закладу спеціальної освіти з
урахуванням особливостей розвитку особи
відповідно зрозуміло щодо профілю або
напрямок спеціальної освіти або МРТ
складається індивідуальна програма у
розвитку для тих осіб е з особливими
освітніми потребами які здобувають
освіту за формою педагогічного патронажу
діти зарахування до спеціальних класів
чи груп з урахуванням особливостей
розвитку таких дітей Також ми не
забуваємо що і це теж ще один виклик ще
повторний комплексний оцінки враховуючи
це навантаження
Звичайно я буду говорити про те що є
певні там зміни які ми чекаємо постанові
тому що повторний комплексних
колекційних даних дуже багато особливо у
літній періоди їх може ініціювати особу
що подала заяву відповідно до частини
четвертої статті четвертої закону
України про освіту ви побачите на екрані
Я не буду це все читати але найчастіше
ніж раз на рік ініціативи батьків або
інших законних представників особового
Пен коли відбувається перехід особи за
опень між рівнями освіти і коли є
рекомендації команди супроводу особи
зооп закладу освіти або фахівців і
рецепти з метою проведення моніторингу
розвитку особи
звичайно повторний комплексну оцінку
дуже багато заявки заяв і тих батьків
які знаходяться за кордоном і хочуть і
планують уже продовжити освітній процес
але навіть не розуміючи як це робити
звичайно і тих які змінюють рівні освіти
тому звичайно були такі дуже ну якби
великий і хочуть також буквально дуже
коротко зупинитися на проєкті постанови
і наголошую що це проєкт це ті зміни які
будуть внесені в ряд постанов Кабінету
Міністрів України і лише зупинитися на
тих змінах які будуть діяти на період
дії воєнного стану тому що вони для нас
важливі
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр те що
стосується і це що ті особи які
здобувають загальну середню освіту
тимчасово перебувають за кордоном або
для осіб які перебувають на тимчасово
окупованих територіях під час переходу
між рівнями освіти дія висновку який
використовується на цей момент Да він
продовжиться на строк дії воєнного стану
думаю дуже правильне рішення і від цього
я впевнена що не побачити якість надання
освітніх послуг але певне розвантаження
ірц було тому я думаю Ну всі чекаємо
Скажем так ці зміни повторна комплексна
оцінка те що я говорила що може бути
проведена не пізніше ніж через три
місяці або після припинення чи
скасування воєнного стану повернення
здобувача освіти за кордоном або
повернення тимчасового окупованої
території на якій проживають здобувають
освіти загально юрисдикцію України
відновлення Конституційного ладу України
на цій території за те що власне Я думаю
не погіршить якість надання освітні
послуг але в принципі з ними рівень
напруги в батьків які зараз хвилюються
що вони цю комплексну оцінку не зможуть
пройти повторно і звичайно тут трішки
дозволить і це визначити ті пріоритети і
Скажімо так той фокус уваги тих дітей на
яких ми зможемо зорієнтуватися також ці
цей проєкт постанови наголошує він теж
мусить термін зміни спеціальної
діяльності
знову ж таки дуже коротко на свою але
вважаю що вони є потрібними вони
потрібні тому що вимушені переселення
вони є вони продовжують я говорю це про
полтавську область не дуже багато
приймаємо дітей які будуть зараховані До
закладів освіти тому спеціальна школа не
все вони можуть зараховувати дітей з ОП
і без і додатково створювати змішані та
інклюзивні класи з відповідною
організацією освітнього процесу і там
індивідуальна програма розвитку це все
буде прописано що ці змішані класи
можуть допомогти вам програмою тому що
декілька слайдів залишилось нам а також
ці класи вони на певний період і ці
постанови це буде прописано і те що для
вас прошу просто програма бо в нас на
наступні люди Я думаю що з цими змінами
Дякую дуже зацінювати
дивіться наступний орієнтир та про який
я говорила це безпечний простір і тут
тоже було багато питань тому що в мене є
закладами освіти тому ми користуємося
тими вимогами до найпростіших викликів
які є Я думаю що всі випро працювати і
їх треба виконувати я просто І фінансую
якщо комусь потрібно презентації це буде
Я так і планувала але це ще говорила що
безпечний простір це не лише про укриття
і тут дуже важливо що ми з вами фахівці
є це до нас звертаються на консультацію
педагога і команди супроводу щоб ми
пояснювали вчителям яка їхня роль і що
вони в новому навчальному році повинні
зробити що вони мають сформувати хоча б
оцю довіру Да Де дитина могла б
зрозуміти що тут є підтримуючи тут і
зрозуміють що та складна поведінка яку
бачить педагоги чи за нею стоять дуже
важливі потреби наші зменшити напругу
зменшити страх чи негативні емоції і
поведінка - це не завжди про якісь
діагнози да Якісь освітні труднощі це
може бути наслідки травматичних спогадів
і те що знову ж таки я говорила
безпечний простір якщо фахівці є все
піклуються про себе турбуються про себе
і директори це турбується про себе то це
буде перший необхідна умова здатності
дитина працювати з дітьми які не тільки
зазнали травмуючих подій але дітьми які
мають особливі освітні потреби тому що
це для нас дуже великий виклик я знаю що
багато фахівців і директорів це з якими
я знайома вони про цей пункт безпечного
простору та у себе в закладі вони
забувають знаєте дуже думала так як би
завершити да про що говорити Я завжди
коли починається новий навчальний рік як
для себе ставлю певні цілі це цілі які я
вважаю ми будемо розглядати от з
колегами Полтавської області на
серпневій конференції Можливо хтось для
себе візьме такі цілі ми будемо говорити
з директорами фахівцями про те що
навчіться зрозуміти як піклуватися про
себе перше в першу чергу і робіть це
тому що наші дуже довго до перемоги нам
ще багато працювати І ми вже задали
такий темпір це що нам не можна
зупинятися а не піклуючись про себе ми
можемо просто на якомусь етапі зійти з
дистанції це встановлення оцей
пріоритетності діяльності чи можливо це
будуть групові хто буде першочергово
тому ми проведемо комплексну оцінку
зараз це треба все дуже чітко вибудувати
тому що ми просто будемо вибирати тому
що ми просто будемо працювати поза
межами своїх скажемо так можливостей і
дуже багато зараз педагогів говорять
Боже що робити новий навчальний рік як
вчити фізику хімію і так далі Ну для
себе ставимо основну ціль нам треба
всьому навчальному році зберегти фізичне
і психічне здоров'я своє і дітей тому що
ми з вами хочемо перемогти наших дітей
Ми з вами переможемо обов'язково але
дітей треба зберегти тому я дякую за
увагу будь ласка якщо презентація Кому
потрібна там все це чітко написано дякую
пані Ірини дуже вам дякую за виступ
Пробачте що прийшлося це був у нас
просто дуже чіткі регламент дуже багато
виступаючи Я думаю що ваші колеги я знаю
що ти зараз працюєте в безпечному
освітньому просторі в закладах з
інклюзивного центру Я думаю що вони
зможете до вас напряму зв'язатися з вами
і ви їх як радістю проконсультуйте тих
щодо тих розопрацювань які вас вже є у
безпечному середовищі бо як сказали яке
весілля що як підкреслює всі ми безпека
дітей і безпека педагогічних працівників
це над е-е важлива задача І це те що є
навіть самим головнішим Я запрошую Дякую
вам ще раз запрошую до слова В'ячеслава
засенка доктора педагогічних наук
професора дійсно члена Академіка
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України радника директора інституту
спеціальної педагогіки і психології
імені Миколи ярмаченка Національної
академії педагогічних наук України з
темою діти з особливими освітніми
потребами викликати сьогодення
дякую дякую пані Ольга чутно
мені дещо буде складно виступати після
фахівця в галузі педагогічної
майстерності пані Ірини і за змістом за
конкретикою тому з вашої ласки кілька
таких напів загальних позицій
насамперед Добрий день шановні колеги
присутні всім кому небайдужа доля дітей
з особливими потребами
Коли ще
1918 році Кирило Григорович Стеценко на
ямпільській нараді вчителів
висловив таку думку що духовно-сильний
той народ у якого є національна школа
і ось в цьому сенсі курс Україна на
європейську інтеграцію потребує зміни
пріоритетів одним з яких і є побудова
національної школи
не є в цьому сенсі винятком ясна річ і
система освіти осіб з особливими
потребами тобто лакмусовим папірцем
цивілізованості суспільства це є
ставлення до осіб з інвалідністю і
ставлення до їхньої освіти
я не зупинятимуся на історичному
екскурсії скажу лише що система як і
система освіти взагалі система освіти
осіб з особливими потребами зазнавала
період становлення змін
пощастий істотних
тобто система змінювалася і
краще але так Ви знаєте що в нашому
житті не змінюється тільки жінки Вони
завжди гарні в будь-якому віці а система
змінювалася і тут потрібно сказати що
наша система освіти
спеціальна освіта і А це люди стосуються
людей з порушеннями слуху зору
опорно-рухового апарату мовлення і так
далі І так далі
попри наявні проблеми все ж одна з
найпотужніших про проблеми я потім
пізніше скажу кілька слів вибіркова одна
з найпотужніших і найкращих Я завжди
коли є можливість наводжу цей приклад що
ви не побачите в нашому суспільстві от
на вулицях
жебраків з числа осіб з особливими
потребами дуже рідко тобто вони все-таки
завдяки вашим зусиллям спільним
навчаються адаптуються соціалізуються і
так далі І так далі я з нашої ласки
нагадаю кілька показників що у нас є
Можливо комусь буде цікаво можливо як
помилюся і найшвидше помилюся бо вони
змінюються але десь орієнтовно в нас Є
320 спеціальних закладів освіти
понад 40 тисяч учнів навчається це мрц і
спеціальні школи в умовах інклюзії
близько 22 тисяч навчається вони 8 тисяч
дошкільні заклади і є у нас що важливо
понад 630 центрів інклюзивно-ресурсних
центрів загалом по Україні це такі
напівафіційні дані Близько трьох
мільйонів
гривень з яких понад 160 тисяч це діти
про яких ми говоримо
хочу сказати що важливо і позитивно є те
що в Україні здійснюється науковий
супровід галузі цієї ланки освіти осіб з
особливими потребами і зокрема от
інститут спеціальної педагогіки і
психології імені Миколи ярмаченка
напевно України який я представляю як
єдина Наукова установа яка не лише
розробляє скажімо там концептуальні
підходи якісь високі матерії а й
безпосередньо забезпечує здійснює
навчально-методичне забезпечення А це
тисячі підручників посібників
навчально-методичних рекомендацій типові
програми критерії оцінювання і так далі
І так далі ось Віктор Васильович щойно
згадував про
програми близько 30 програм було
затверджена прийнято На комісії тобто
постійно оновлюється і система
забезпечення
причому забезпечені всі типи
забезпечуються всі типи закладів по
можливості вона функціонує і функціонує
успішно хочу сказати що новий поштовх до
зміни знову ж таки системи освіти
надала нуш концептуальні положення нуш
що будуть стосуватися і вже стосуються
часткової змісту і методик роботи
складним випробуванням для нашої системи
для держави в цілому стала
епідеміологічна ситуація що пов'язано з
ковідом і ясна річ вплинуло на реформи
викладання тобто дистанційне навчання
активізувалося специфічна колекційна
розвивальна розвивальна робота
проводилася супровід і так далі І так
далі І тут
вкрай важлива ситуація чи Важка ситуація
трагічна ситуація склалася у зв'язку з
війною з нападом фашистської Росії ви
знаєте і до існуючих проблем про які я
обіцяв згадати
додалася ще ціла нитка скажімо до таких
проблем як от я собі помітив навіть
розширення практики перед дошкільної
підготовки проблема є є раннє виявлення
дітей про яке ми вже говоримо не один
рік і
вплив корекційний в цьому віці на них
соціальна педагогічний патронат тобто
школа сім'я суспільства
супровід навчання соціалізація дітей з
аутистичним спектром складними
комбінованими порушеннями
святкування профільного навчання це
окрема проблема яка не вирішена як на
мене і в загально загальноосвітній школі
подальше запровадження інноваційних форм
інклюзивного навчання Яка поправлена яке
по право набуває
поширення
важливо забезпечення як проблема як
питання
забезпечення наступності між ланками
освітніми в контексті нової української
школи і так далі І так далі І ось до цих
проблем у зв'язку з
воєнним станом
додалися такі як скажімо онлайн навчання
це
та форма яка зараз ну на першому місці
власне
супровід не лише дітей
потрібен супровід і цілих родин таких
дітей кадрова підготовка потребує
вирішення багатьох питань оскільки
значна частина педагогічного складу
не може працювати
не готова працювати в умовах воєнного
стану і не звикла Скажімо так не зовсім
опанувала нові форми викладання
нанесення матеріалу
а Умови що склалися дійсно вражаючі
виїхали тисячі таких дітей з особливими
потребами от я нещодавно в отозі
з'ясовував близько 800 чоловік тільки
виїхало дітей з порушеннями слуху
і це на тлі того що окремі заклади
зруйновані взагалі знищено
і ясна річ що в цих умовах
забезпечити не те що навчання А і
корекційний супровід якийсь
психолог-педагогічний супровід дуже
складно До речі я хочу сказати вам що
інституті зараз в цьому контексті з
огляду на всі ці ситуації
робиться
значна Робота От зараз залишається стан
стан руйнувань приміщень
наших закладів склад педагогів хто
лишився хто Хто де склад учнів які
методичні труднощі і так далі І це
позиція принципова і позиція щодо
вивчення цієї ситуації прийнята на
трагедія Національної академії наук І от
зараз цим займаються наші співробітники
водночас
співробітниками інституту які
продовжують працювати от фактично в
штатному режимі і керівництво працює в
штатному режимі надається різна спектна
допомога як педагогам так і ясна річ
батькам таких дітей зокрема в онлайн
режимі проводяться курси підвищення
кваліфікації
це дуже важливо при цьому там курси
адаптовано
оптимізовано в контексті отих позицій
тих вимог про які я говорив що педагоги
не готові працювати
здійснюється дистанційне консультування
допомога практична працівникам і
батьками в мережі YouTube постійно
діючий семінар з інклюзивної
інклюзивного навчання
створимо YouTube канал українська
жестова мова
постійно функціонує при аспірантурі
психолог психологічний консультативна
тренінговий центр це Скажімо так наші
діти ще і нове керівництво
докладає багато зусиль щоб він активно
працював і це вдається Де здійснюється
консультативна психодіагностична
психокорекційна та психолога тренінгова
діяльність в тому числі і в онлайн режим
запроваджено проект психологічний
супровідродим дітей з особливими
потребами в кризових ситуаціях що теж на
часі Тобто я не кажу окремо там
підготовлено цілу низку відповідних
посібників поради батькам І так далі І
так далі
Як бачите багато проблем і багато роботи
думається не думається що спільними
зусиллями управлінців науковців
практиків ми зможемо подолати оцей цей
стан цю скруту ці труднощі і максимально
підтримати навіть незахищенішу
підкреслюю категорії громадян осіб з
особливими потребами я на сам кінець
хочу з вашої ласки подякувати
організаторам конференції працівника
Міністерства освіти і науки які присутні
які відсутні з якими ми дуже стильно і
щільно щільно до зусильно працюємо
працівникам і це до речі зараз
значна частина інклюзивно-ресурсних
центрів тут присутні представники можуть
це підтвердити надає дистанційну
допомогу тим особам зоопрам які
знаходяться за межами України і ясна річ
хочу подякувати педагогам практикам а
саме вам шановні друзі втілювати в життя
оте все розумне А можливо і не зовсім що
розробляють вчені І що приймають
управління
тож всього вам самого доброго як я
завжди кажу
самого-самого доброго під мирним небом і
накли козацького здоров'я тримаємося Ми
переможемо Слава Україні
Дуже дякую вам за ваш виступ Дуже дякую
за всю ту роботу яка робиться
національна академія педагогічних наук
для наших фізичних працівників щоб
підтримати їх і наукову методичні і дуже
окремо Дякую за спеціальної педагогіки
який психології Ломаченка за те що ви
е-е займаєтесь безпосередньо розробкою
усіх народів працювального методичних
для наших центрів для наших закладів
освіти для дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами ви робите дуже велику роботу
дуже дякую вам за вашу безпосередню і
участь сьогоднішню і роботу яку здійснює
інститут кожного дня Дуже дякую
тобі надають слова Олесі гладушині і
координаторці освітніх програм дії сет
України з темою спільно до навчання
стратегія та ініціатива ініціатив з
підтримки дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами пані Олеся тут зараз зі мною в
студії тому вона Зараз Пі
Доброго дня всім дякую за запрошення та
можливість виступити юнісеф міжнародного
організація яка займається багатьма
напрямками це і освіта і соціальна
інклюзія охорона здоров'я створення
старого розвитку і передусім зусиллям
юнісевих спрямовані на створення спряту
допомог для розвитку дітей та молоді а
також забезпечення прав кожного дитини і
одне з пріоритетів для юнісеф є розвиток
інклюзивної освіти
А яка не тільки надає можливість
ефективно навчатися та символізуватися
але також інклюзивна освіта - це про
усування бар’єрів та стереотипів
стосовно дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами
юнісеф має декілька проектів у сфері
інклюзивної освіти так протягом останніх
років
юнісель сприяв публікації
посібниках організаційно-методичним
засад діяльності інклюзивно-ресурсного
центру де надається аспекти
поради щодо створення та функціонування
ірц також у співпраці з українськими
інститутом розвитку освіти юнісеф
підготував практичні рекомендації для
освітян щодо забезпечення інклюзивності
в освітньому середовищі і зокрема під
час онлайн навчання
через війну багато дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами вони
опинилися в складних обставинах через
вимушену евакуацію переселення та
призупинення навчання і на нових місцях
такі діти вони стикалися з обмеженим
доступом до інклюзивних послуг для того
щоб зрозуміти потреби таких дітей та
Агромат юнісе як разом з мистецтвами
освіти і науки інститутом освітнього
аналітики та успінням класом провів
опитування серед громад більше ніж 1000
громад прийняли участь у цьому
опитуванні і ми хотіли дізнатися що саме
потребують громади щодо освітньої
інфраструктури
також якщо вони
потребують психосоціальну допомогу і
одним з компонентом цього опитування
була також інклюзивна освіта а громади
зазначили що вони потребують тренди для
педагогічних працівників щодо
інклюзивної освіти є необхідність
методичних рекомендаціях з організації
інклюзівного навчання А також громади
потребують обладнання для організації
інклюзивного навчання в загальних школах
спеціалізованих школах та навчальної
реабілітаційний центр і діти в таких
громадах вони також потребують допоміжні
засоби для навчання в тому числі і
дистанційного навчання і зокрема мова
йде про дітей з порушенням зору та слуху
а Юність для того щоб підтримати таких
дітей запровадив програму кризову
підтримки
сімей дітей і юнісеф
зараз секундочку
і юнісеф надає допомогу сім'ям з дітьми
з інвалідністю А які потребують
кризового втручання також допомога
надається в рамку цієї програми якщо у
дітей подібності фізичної або
психологічний стан якщо немає бо
втрачено спеціалізоване обладнання а
також якщо сім'ї не мають інформації про
послуги громадах
А
яку саме допомогу юнісеф надає це
індивідуальна консультація послуги
соціальних працівників також надаються
консультації вузьких спеціалістів А
юнісеф може надати допоміжні засоби для
дітей наприклад це здавали сухові
апарати та крісла колісні і також в разі
необхідності наша мобільна команда
фахівців може виїхати у віддалений
райони та надати відповідні послуги
щодо результатів спочатку війни
щонайменше 22 тисячі дітей в тому числі
більше ніж 4000 дітей з обмеженою
можливостями Вони отримують допомогу
дитині сел Це була гуманітарна підтримка
медичне обслуговування та
спеціалізованої послуги 38 тисяч батьків
опікуни та соціальних працівників
отримали психологічну підтримку та
пройшли навчальну підготовку а також 500
дітей з вадами слуху в тому числі з них
Це було 400 дітей при зеленсів вони
отримали допоміжні пристрої та медичні
та спеціалізовані послуги
а також Юність як має проект разом з
центром джерелом щодо підтримки
використання системних технологій для
подальшого залучення дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами до інклюзивної
освіти в рамках всього проекту ми
проводимо тренди для працівників ірц
вчителів та асистентів вчителя з
використання системних технологій
зокрема Зараз ми проводимо три роки та
айстрикером також надаємо ліцензії по
оборт на якій родині Артем проводимо
тренки для батьків щоб ознайомити їх з
можливастями асистивних технологій та як
саме можна використовувати ці технології
готуємо дітей за інтерактивним до школи
А саме ми запитуємо дітей допоміжними
технологіями як то хутори для айстриків
та проводимо адаптаційні роботи в школах
і також плануємо запровадити
наставництво спеціаліст ірц вчителів та
асистентів вчителя по застосуванні
Також у нас є співпраця з української
освітньою платформою і ми підтримуємо
інклюзивний результат центри і у
Львівській Тернопільській
івано-франківській областях ми передали
55 ірц по два планшета для того щоб їх
підтримати їх роботі
а юнісеф також стає зусилля для
створення цифрових навчальних ресурсів
для дітей з особливими освітніми
потребами наразі ми
удосконалюємо навчально онлайн
патрульному всеукраїнська школа онлайн
та працюємо над тим щоб запровадити
функціонал на цій платформі для того щоб
користувачі з вадами зору Також ми могли
ефективно користуватися ними
для того щоб розпочати навчальний рік а
вже треба забезпечити школи необхідним
оснащенням і оснащити укриття з
урахуванням потреб дітей та рекомендації
державної служби надзвичайних ситуацій і
ми проводимо ремонт та облаштовуємо
укриття Також для того щоб діти з
інвалідністю могли користуватися ними
і коротко розповім про нашу компанію
спільно для навчання яку гинуть
запровадив для того щоб підготуватися до
відновлення навчання З 1 вересня в
будь-якому форматі Ця компанія має три
основних компонента це навчання у школі
дома та громаді і наша ідея Наша
компанія вона спрямована на те щоб усі
ці три компоненти вони співпрацювали всі
енергії та надавали можливості для дітей
не тільки навчатися а також спілкуватися
з соціалізуватися з ровесниками з
однолітками і основний компоненція цієї
кампанії це підвищення бізнес-терності
змінної безпеки залученість і розвиток
мов і в тому числі молоді з інвалідністю
з особливими потребами а також надання
підтримки психічного здоров'я та
благополуччя
сподіваюсь що розвиток інклюзивної
освіти буде і надалі активно розвиватися
в Україні і юність Я завжди буду
підтримувати цей процес
дякую
дякую пані Олеся за те що ви
представилися тільки напрацювання які є
в університеті які їм здійснює для того
щоб дітям не тільки з особливостями
потребами а будь-якій дитині в Україні
було зручно і комфортно навчатися щоб
вона змогла отримати освітні послуги які
відповідають її потребам і щоби наші
діти могли навчатися дуже вам дякую за
всю роботу яка здійснює ініцеф для
допомоги Україні Тим паче в цій складні
часи військових дій - це допомога є
безцінною дуже важливою для нас
наступний виступаючий запрошую до слова
пані Оксану савицького державного
експерта експертної групи з питань
дошкільної освіти директорату дошкільної
шкільної та дошкільної та інклюзивної
освіти мон консультант з питань
психічного здоров'я та психологічної
соціальної підтримки Юнеско пані Оксано
вас до слова з темою психологічна
підтримка учасників освітнього процесу
Спасибі Пані Оля я вам дуже дякую
Скажіть мені будь ласка видно мою
презентацію
презентацію Оля від виднової спасибі Я
дякую за запрошення і дякую пані Олесі
за те що вона так чітко і влучно
окреслила те коло заходів підтримки які
здійснює юнісеф наразі для продовження
навчання наших дітей щирі слова
вдячності Я мабуть зупинюся трошки на
практичному аспекті і хочу вас
познайомити з одним із
практичних інструментів психологічного
інтервенції яка може застосовуватися як
системний підхід в будь-якій установі в
тому числі врц і я би зробила акцент на
закладах освіти ви як установи які
будете встановлювати наявність
освітніх потреб у дітей через
психологічну травму яку вони отримали
думають що це інструмент буде вам в
нагоді і принаймні для ознайомлення щоб
ви знали що такий інструмент наразі
існує і
апробований Отже повномасштабна
російська агресія спричинила масштабні
страждання це впливає на психічне
здоров'я про яке сьогодні вже згадували
і
психосоціальне благополуччя дітей
Скажіть будь ласка мої слайди змінюються
та Спасибі
Отже постраждалі групи населення
зазнають впливи великої кількості
стресових чинників через війну як
наслідок багато людей в тому числі і
дітей і педагогів будуть з цими
наслідками стикатися під час освітнього
процесу вже з вересня поширені такі
реакції як проблеми зі сном втома яка
буде проявлятися під час навчання
хвилювання в ройових гніву фізичні болі
порушення апетиту і так далі І такі
ситуації можуть взагалі порушувати весь
когнітивний емоційний соціальний
фізичний розвиток дітей і спричиняти
певні довготривалі наслідки негативні
довготривалі наслідки для їхнього
майбутнього
Отже ми можемо констатувати Я перепрошую
можемо констатувати що Ось ті учасники
освітнього процесу як діти так і
педагогічні працівники мати психологічну
травму різного ступеня І потребуватимуть
психологічної підтримки трошки
статистики для того щоб ви розуміли
масштаб проблеми і я наголошую що ці
дані є неперевіреними та тобто вони
умовні і є підозри є основою вважати що
ці цифри набагато більше за даними
всесвітньої організації охорони здоров'я
в районах постраждалих від конфлікту вже
нині кожна п'ята людина живе з певною
формою психічного порушення Крім того в
українців які постраждали внаслідок і
нижче з 2014 року найчастіше
спостерігається посттравматичний
стресовий розлад близько 32%. депресія
близько 22% тривожність 17% і так далі І
так далі інші інші прояви
з якими Нам доведеться працювати в
наступному році з попередніми оцінками
Міністерства охорони здоров'я України -
це найсвіжіші дані через війну
психологічної підтримки потребуватимуть
близько 15 мільйонів українців і прояви
цієї психологічної травми будуть
абсолютно абсолютно різними і наші
педагоги мають бути готові до цих
проявів під час під час навчання
якщо ми подивимося на дані державної
служби статистики України то за минулий
рік тобто до 24 умовного лютого цього
року в системі освіти загалом на всіх
рівнях освіти перебувала більше 6,7
мільйонів здобувачів освіти Тобто це
окреслює масштаб масштаб проблеми і
трагедії так якщо ми
зважаємо на те що частина частина
поїхала з території України 760 тисяч
педагогічних працівників понад через 760
тисяч і близько чотирьох з половиною
мільйонів дітей змушені залишити свої
домівки і звичне життя через війну ще
однозначно вплинуло на їх
психологічний стан
тому інтегрування послуг із підтримки
психічного здоров'я сектору освіти є
надзвичайно важливим І звісно що це може
допомогти посилити систему загалом і
мати це посилення в довготривалій
перспективі
заклади освіти різних рівнів освіти вони
відіграють вагому роль у промоції
психічного здоров'я і позитивного
добробуту загалом серед дітей зокрема і
серед дорослих Чим же саме можуть
сприяти заклади освіти підтримці
психічного здоров'я і надання допомоги
це промоція соціальної емоційного
здоров'я здобувачів освіти це виявлення
дітей з високим ризиком спричиненим
певними причинами і не лише війна це
може це спричиняти це можуть бути
економічний стан родини Так це можуть
бути стосунки родинні і так далі Я думаю
що ви всі про це знаєте не будемо
детально на цьому зупинятися а також для
виявити дітей в яких починаються кризи
або якісь страждають від проблеми з
психічним здоров'я потребують більш
спеціалізованої експертної допомоги і
саме запровадження отого системного
підходу про які я буду говорити воно має
забезпечити
всебічний супровід дитини не лише під
час навчання які забезпечуються в
закладі освіти а й надання
спеціалізованої допомоги цій дитині поза
межами закладу освіти тобто тут ми вже
говоримо про необхідність налагодження
алгоритмів перенаправлення дитини з
одного сектору в іншу тобто сектору
освіти в сектор медицини і в разі
виявлення подібних проблем у дітей
закладу освіти є на мою думку ідеальним
середовищем для надання певних видів
спеціалізованої цільової підтримки в
класі в групі і поза його межами для
того щоб допомогти Таким дітям впоратись
з навчальними вимогами і досягти
найкращих результатів навчання Адже для
практичних психологів закладів в
закладах освіти це найперше завдання
забезпечити організацію такого таку
організацію освітнього процесу під час
якої навіть за наявності глибинної
психологічної травми дитина зможе
навчатися і досягати успішних
результатів
так от говорячи про цей практичний
інструмент враховуючи автономію закладів
освіти
в закладі освіти або в або в тому числі
ірц в будь-якій іншій установі Тобто це
інструмент є універсальним можуть бути
впроваджені так званий мінімальний пакет
послуг з охорони психічного здоров'я
психосоціальної підтримки які охоплює
певний перелік основних заходів а також
додаткових заходів в залежності від того
яким чином цей пакет буде адаптований до
потреб конкретної установи і це
мінімальний пакет він був розроблений на
основі численних досліджень документів в
консультації обговорення аналізів що
проводились ключовими зацікавленими
особами на міжнародному регіональному
місцевих рівнях і я хочу зауважити що це
проект версії
мінімальний пакет послу для пілотного
тестування наразі Він знаходиться на
етапі перевірок з боку всесвітньої
організації охорони здоров'я юнісеф
колегія сьогодні присутні і інших
партнерів і фіналізована версія
запланована на листопад 22-го року
більш детально ви можете ознайомити за
посиланням яке ви бачите наразі на
презентації
візуально Ви можете бачити також на
презентації посібник перекладений
українською мовою в якому є деталізована
інформація щодо цього інструменту там ви
можете завантажити цю українську версію
посібника в ній є детальний опис
рекомендованих сфер застосування цього
мінімального пакету є відповідна
візуалізація яка полегшує вибір там є
освітній сектор можна одразу
орієнтуватися Які заходи можна
застосовувати в секторі освіти порядок
проведення оцінювання потреб конкретно
конкретній установі в конкретному
закладі обґрунтування для необхідності
впровадження цього мінімального пакету
різні алгоритми
приватизація осіб групи ризику які мають
бути охоплені в першу чергу це
мінімальним пакетом способи надання цих
послуг короткий огляд заходів алгоритми
координації і і таке інше крім того є
опис моніторингу оцінки ефективності і
сприяння розвитку компетенції у сфері
психічного здоров'я психосоціальної
підтримки серед персоналу що теж не менш
важлива адже інституційна спроможність в
першу чергу залежить від готовності
педагогічних працівників
справлятися з труднощами які спричинила
війна і пов'язані з
психологічною травою
загалом від цього інструменту від цього
мінімального пакету очікується Що
використання його в закладі освіти
призведе до більш передбачуваних і
неупередженого реагування на прояви
психологічної травми дітей під час
навчання тому що запити з якими ми зараз
стикаємося від практичного психологів в
тому числі Дайте будь ласка алгоритми
реагування що має робити як реагувати
педагогічних працівників якщо він під
час освітнього процесу стикається з
такими проявами і зрештою використання
цього інструменту воно має покращити
психічне здоров'я і загальне
психосоціальне благополуччя
дітей цей пакет охоплює певні Заходи які
можуть бути впроваджені фахівцями
різного досвіду і різного рівня освіти
це дуже важливо оскільки побутує думка
що
психосоціальну підтримку можуть надавати
виключно психологи це не так оскільки є
певний базовий пакет навичок для
педагогів і для інших не фахівців у
сфері психології які можуть вже зараз
під час прояву
ознак психологічної травми надати дитині
підтримку і допомоги і це дуже важливо
оскільки це розвантажує практично
психолога в закладі освіти і допомагає
йому працювати з тими випадками які є
складними і залучати в межах між
секторальної взаємодії інших фахівців
оскільки з реалізація цих заходів в
цьому мінімальному пакеті вона
передбачає коорди тоді і співпрацю
різних секторів звісно Ми свідомі того
що покриття учасників освітнього процесу
послугами цього мінімального пакету воно
спочатку буде обмеженим і воно має в
першу чергу включати дітей групу ризику
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами
які потребують мабуть найбільшої
підтримки для того щоб нормалізувати їх
освітній процес і зробити його
максимально успішним але
принаймні це на сьогодні дієвий
інструмент який можна використовувати І
що тішить що є україномовна дипломна
адаптована версія і вона дуже детально
прописана я Буду намагатися дотриматись
ліміту я вам дякую за увагу якщо будуть
якісь питання стосовно цього інструменту
або інші питання щодо практичних
інструментів будь ласка звертайтеся бо
до моїх колег або на електронну адресу
яку ви зараз бачите на екрані Всім
спасибі мирного неба над головою і
плідною плідного завершення
сьогоднішньої зустрічі Спасибі Пані Оля
передаю вам слово Дуже дякую пані Оксана
за те що ви так
висвітили практичний аспект це дуже є
важливим тому дуже вам дякую за ваш
виступ і за інформацією яка була надана
і за роботою яка здійснюється Дуже дякую
До наступного виступу Я запрошую
Катерину довго поле кандидата довголу
кандидата психологічних наук дитячого
психолога старше науково співробітника
зі зброєю спеціальною педагогіки і
психології імені Миколи ярмаченка
Національної академії педагогічних наук
волонтера проекту підтримує дитину вона
представить тему роботи з дітьми що
мають особливість які потреби внаслідок
психологічної
співправачем буду я
навіть не знаю чи треба мене через е-е
треба мене через
представляти
Отже я почну з
свою маленьку таку преступну частину
ви всі знаєте що ми змінили підходи
трохи зміни підходить до визначення
особливих освітніх потреб в
інклюзивно-ресурсний центр і розширили
категорію
соціальних труднощів у навчанні дні
розширили можливими одною з причинної от
судилося тоді потреб за цією типом
труднощів можуть бути те саме
психологічну практику чому ми це зробили
бо ми розуміємо що нас даний момент є
дуже важливим аспект допомоги дітям які
постраждали внаслідок військової дії
внаслідок інформаційних психологічних
атак які здійснюється
загарбниками по відношенню до України і
діти які ми першими що страждають в цій
ситуації тому що вони не себе приймають
інформаційні психологічні вони є більш
чутливими і відповідно реагують Більше
Більш гостро можуть реагувати на
різноманітні події
я зупинюся тут дуже коротко зазначу що в
гарвардському університеті в центрі
розвитку дитини було визначено три
основних типи
стресу краще це стресу це позитивність
для своїх Він стосується він ми завжди
Кожен з нас зустрічається з цим типом
стресу це він викликає Такі ж самі
реакції нашого організму як і в
будь-якому іншому стресі але цей стрес
він переходить в дослід його прикладом є
стрес який може виникнути коли дитина
йде в перший раз в школу коли дитина в
перший раз іде
виступає на сцені ми всі або ми дорослі
люди в перший раз це йдемо на нову
роботу ми відчуваємо стрес ми хвилюємося
але ми вміємо цей подолати і це якісь
стрес в нас в принципі перейде в наш
досвід він не потребує додаткової в
більшості випадків він не працює як у
додаткової допомоги
наступний процес - це терпимий стрес він
передбачає те що теж організм реагує але
стресовий фактор є може бути більш
травматичним для дитини і він може
потребувати вже значного може
підготувати допомогу зі сторони
дорослого або зі сторони психолога це
такими прикладами наприклад може бути
коли дитина впала і вдарилася впала з
висоти вдарилася Вона може подальшому
боятися висоти якщо вона
здійснилася якусь іншу дію я там на неї
накричали чи вона там якось
отримала якусь травму Вона може в
подальшому цей такий от терпимий стрес
він може в подальшому впливати і в неї
буде психологічний трав в мене все життя
або його не буде і цю траву досить легко
подолати якщо дитині вчасно пояснити
вчасно її підтримати Якщо батьки з її
підтримати і в більшості випадків вона
не буде потребувати такого втручання І
ми теж з кожен
зіштовхувалася але ми її змогли подолати
наступний вид стресу це терпимість стрес
це стрес який
вперше токсичний стрес стрес який
пов'язаний з він також визиває реакцію
організму це теж саме але це стрес який
впливає дуже на дитину він має він стає
наслідком якоїсь загрози життю дитини
фізичного психологічного
сексуального чи будь-якого іншого виду
насильства він може бути не не за один
раз або це гострий за один раз або це
довготривалий якийсь менші але якраз
військові дії відносяться до тих
факторів які можуть викликати в дитини
такий токсичний стрес і цей стрес може
привести до гострого психологічної
травми
може привести в подальшому до
посттравматичного синдрому з такими
дітьми потрібно надалі працювати для
того щоб їм допомогти в цьому аспекті
дуже великого значення і набуває
вміння педагога а також вміння батьків
визначити що в дитини є ознаки
психологічної практики чому це важливо
тому що на перших етапах коли ці ознаки
чоловічої травми помітить батьки або
педагогічні працівники вони зможуть
зреагувати допомогти дитині і вивести
його з такого стану або звернути увагу
на те що цій дитині потрібно вже
кваліфікована психологічна допомога яку
може здійснити психотерапевт або
психолог і це є дуже важливим зараз ви
бачите слайд на якому написано Я
пристосувати травматичний стрес у дитини
я не буду зупинятися на кожній віковій
категорії тому що я розумію це тема
окремого семінару Отже в принципі
проводили такий семінар з методом ще в
в березні чи травні місяці але і
намагалися там це пояснити і також ми
виходили з такими ж самими семінарами і
для Міністерства
внутрішніх справ України і для ітак в
нас був для вихователів дошкільних
закладів і на наступному тижні 23-го
числа буде в семінар Міністерства освіти
науки України для керівників закладів
дошкільної освіти де знову таки будуть
підніматися ці питання але я вам
рекомендую ця інфографіка була зроблена
Міністерство освіти науки України вона
зможе вам бути таким от як сказати
правильно
шпаргалкою допоміжним таким засобом який
не дасть вам можливість розпізнати
дитини ознаки драматичного стресу
звернути увагу додатково на цю дитину бо
можливо саме цій дитині потрібна не
просто додатково до вашого увагу а
можливо вже буде треба допомо
Кожна з цих вікових категорій вона
описана в цьому слайді в цьому
інфографіці або кожна з вікових
категорій починаючи від наймолодшого в
них є свої реакції у дітей дошкільного
віку старшого дошкільного віку це своїй
реакції в шкільному віку до 12 років це
окремої тип реакції але найскладніші
реакції будуть в підлітків тому що
підлітки вони можуть зовсім не проявляти
На яких таких почуттів емоцій не
говорити про свої якісь
про свій складний стан в для тих дітей
характерно вважати що вони вже можуть зі
всім цим справитися самостійно але саме
підлітків вони будуть можуть проявляти
свої стан і наркотичними залежностями і
спільності до самогубства і депресивними
проявами і
ризикованою поведінкою що є дуже
страшним наслідком коли дитина
може
Своєю поведінкою провокувати певні
ризиковані ситуації із цих ризикованих
ситуацій може отримати школу всі ці
аспекти є дуже важливим Я вас прошу
знайти хвилинку і на сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки познайомитися з цим
слайдом також з цим інфографіку також
вся інфографіка є на Фейсбуці мистецтві
науки України є в є в на моїй кислий
сторінці є в інших джерел в тому числі є
в телеграм-паналі підтримати дитину бо
вони будуть виступали адміністративною
проблем Я також попрошу їх у нас знову
продублюють і в принципі якщо треба буде
я можу повідомляти на свою сторінку в
Фейсбуці або
Отже далі Я
окреслювала лише тільки початкові ці для
того щоб ви зрозуміли важливість цього і
для того щоб ви звертали увагу на те щоб
дитини можуть бути такі реакції і вони
можуть бути в підстави для в неї
наявності в неї особливі потреби тому що
психологічна травма е-е
пост драматичний стрес вони впливають на
весь процес навчання далі я передаю
слово свої доповідачу яка коротко вам
окреслить шляхи як працювати з такою
дитиною пані і Катерина
так подякою Ольга Олександрівна дякую за
надане слово Я розумію що у нас не так
багато часу залишається тож я постараюсь
бути максимально лаконічною і розставити
кілька важливих акцентів будь ласка
Зверніть увагу що ми всі знаємо що діти
з особливими освітніми потребами Вони
вимагають певної делікатності і
коректності під час спілкування з ними
так Але у нас за ці майже півроку
виникла нова категорія дітей які
отримали свої
якісь особливості внаслідок війни і вони
потребують ще більш акуратного і
делікатного підходу З чим це зв'язано Ну
наприклад з тим що по-перше вони можуть
досі перебувати в ситуації
гострою гострематичного аналі або
посттравматичного стресу вони можуть
досі бути під впливом стресових факторів
а навіть якщо вони вже вийшлись під їх
впливу Зверніть увагу що вони ще можливо
не прийшли ту стадію коли вони змогли
отримати
реалістичну
самоідентифікацію себе тобто вони ще не
усвідомили тих змін які в них відбува- в
них відбулись відбулись їхні родині І
тому Ну насправді будь-яке необережне
слово як дорослих так і інших дітей може
їх травмувати додатково і так і тому
педагогічним працівникам потрібно бути
дуже обережними і проводити підготовчу
роз'яснювальну роботу і з усіма
педагогічними працівниками які працюють
з цією дитиною і навіть з технічним
персоналом там в їдальні або ще десь
може зустрітися дитина так і з
однолітками Та звісно обов'язково з
батьками
наступний слайд будь ласка
так
також хочу ще такі наступні акцент
зробити що діти які були поранені які
отримали фізичні та або психологічні
травми можуть викликати у інших як дітей
так і дорослих бажання їх пожаліти так і
це для цілком нормальне природне бажання
ну в ньому немає нічого такого поганого
але ми як педагогічний працівники
повинні пам'ятати що ми хочемо і ми
прагнемо до того щоб уникати з тих
монетизацій всіх дітей тобто ми повинні
працювати над тим щоб вони не сприймали
себе як жертви Ні бо це не те чого вони
потребують насправді ми повинні щоденно
працювати із ними і з батьками і з
іншими людьми однолітками щоб ці діти
почали сприймати себе як переможців Як
тих що змогли вижити пройти через цю
ситуацію і дуже сильнішими
наступний слайд будь ласка
так а що ще один важливий акцент А який
може забезпечити До речі школа дуже
гарно і родина і школа - це почуття
безпеки вже ми говорили проби одна з
попередніх виступаючих багато
наголошувала про безпечний простір і
говорила що це не тільки стіни і сховища
а люди і стосунки так і є такий дуже
простий інструмент створення відчуття
безпеки і відчуття контролю над власним
життям Я Хочу наголосити що для дітей з
особливими освітніми потребами це
інструмент є ще більш дієвим і ще Більш
важливим ніж для звичайних інших дітей і
це такий простий інструмент як створення
і дотримання звичайних щоденних
однакових рутин Та це ті звичайні дії
які ми робимо кожного кожен день і школа
Дуже багато може в цьому плані зробити
для цих дітей це взагалі сам по собі
процес відновлення навчання освітній
процес вже є така
рутинний процес який сигналізує дитині
щоб все в порядку так дорослі тримають
ситуацію перед контролем Все нормально
Мені не треба прямо зараз боротися за
своє життя Я можу займатися своїми
важливими віковими завданнями розвитку а
саме там вчитися гратися там отримувати
освіту так тому такий звичайний прості
ритуали як ранкове коло так як
дотримання режиму дня Як початок і
закінчення уроків в один і той самий час
як воно там виконання домашнього
завдання про щоденна прогулянка якісь
спільне декорування кабінетів там до
осені до якого свята вони всі такі
прості Дії говорять нашим дітям що все в
порядку Все добре Ти можеш зосередитися
на їх
дитячих але при цьому надзвичайно
важливе завдання будь ласка наступний
слайд так і тут я хочу сказати про те що
травма Так є певною раною душевною раною
яка може
яка може порівняти по аналогії з
фізичною травмою так може загноїтися
може перейти хронічну форму і все життя
турбувати людину або навіть дуже сильно
погіршити її стан або Навпаки вона може
зажити і надати дитині людині Той досвід
який з майбутнього буде позитивним для
неї це є такий термін він називається як
посттравматичне зростання що це таке Це
позитивна психологічна зміна яка
відбулася внаслідок кризової ситуації
або інших викликів і вона дозволяла
особи
піднятися на вищий рівень її
функціонування так хочу звернути увагу
що це зростання не може відбуватися
просто
механічно як безпосередньо результат
травми тобто якщо є травма може бути
зростання а може не бути Тому треба
звернути увагу так що
від нас від дорослих дуже багато
залежить
від того чи відбудеться це
посттравматичне зростання у наших дітей
і тут школа може відіграти дуже велику
роль оскільки вона надає один із таких
дуже важливих факторів як соціальна
підтримка яка дозволить дітям
битися як травми в ситуацію
посттравматичного навчання так а я думаю
що гарна школа підтримує не тільки дітей
але і педагогічних працівників Дякую
наступне слайд
Я хочу сказати що по-перше я хочу
дуже-дуже подякувати Міністерство освіти
і науки за те що запросили нас на цей
семінар і за те щоб вони
відгукуються на всі наші ініціативи і
надають підтримку
власне всім учасникам освітнього процесу
приємно це бачити чути і відчувати в
себе за спиною що ми не самі а за нами
стоїть велика команда Також я хочу
подякувати всім всім знаєте насправді
хочу подякувати всім освітянам і всім
батькам які кожного дня докладають
зусиль для того щоб підтримати своїх
дітей і я би хотіла сказати чужих ну це
неправда тому що я вірю в те що чужих
дітей не буває і всі діти наші і також
хочу запросити вас до нас на сторінки
telegram-каналу підтримує дитину та інші
наші сторінки де ви знайдете
додаткові матеріали щодо того щодо
психологі
підтримки дітей які перебувають в
кризовому становищі або були і вже
вийшли звідти і також на наших
каналах ви можете знайти матеріали для
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами
Дякую Якщо у вас є питання будь ласка ви
можете звернутися за визначеними
адресами ми вам допоможемо
Дякую Катерино за представлену
інформацію за короткий такий огляд того
що
психологічна травма як може це Стоїть
над травма впливати на дітей і також
Вдячна вам за вашу вдячні вам за
безпосередньо цю роботу якусь
здійснюється ви і вашу команду для
підтримки дітей для підтримки роботи
проектів які направлені на постійне
інформування батьків і постійної
педагогічних працівників
психологічної травми щодо тих завдань і
їх прав які можуть бути використані з
дітьми ви залишили там на останніх
сторінці з посиланням куди можна
подивитися матеріали де можна поєднатися
я так швидко прошу за можливості
розмістити і посилання на сьогоднішню
конференцію на своєму ресурсі щоб люди
могли знайомитися А також інфографіки
про які були які були продемонстровані і
якщо їх хтось
дитина захоче поділитися якоюсь своїх
частин своєї презентації Я думаю що ви
теж можуть там розмістити на телеграм
каналі підтримує дитину і зможете там
наші колеги зможе там ознайомитися
наступним вам дякую Вам ще раз наступним
кого Я запрошую до до нашої наради це
смірнової Євгенія вона є директором
державної установи школи супергероїв а
також вона є тим безпосереднім
супергероєм який вже не один рік в
якості волонтерської організації
здійснював надання освітніх послуг в
закладах охорони здоров'я для дітей які
перебувають на лікуванні а також дітей
які перебувають на реабілітації ви
знаєте що ця аспект є дуже зараз
важливим тому що є
значна кількість дітей яка перебуває яка
отримала травму яка постраждала від
фізичного або сексуального або інших
видів насильства Ці діти перебувають в
лікарнях в кожну з цих дітей має
є не лише отримувати безпосередньо
освітні послуги it отримувати
психологічну підтримку і безпосередньо
Школа супергероїв займається цим і за
підтримкою оцю найскладнішу категорію
яка потребує нашої додаткової уваги і
нашу додаткову підтримку Іспанії Євгенія
виступить з темою забезпечення освітніх
послуг для дітей що прибувають у
закладах охорони здоров'я пані Євгенія
вас до слова
Вітаю вас вітаю всіх
так багато
сказати що ви справжні Супергерої тому
що ви зараз займаєтеся
самоосвітою щоб зробити освіту краще для
наших діток Я знаю що ви це робите в
непростий для вас час Нам складно і про
це ми маємо говорити Ми маємо не мовчати
але я вам надзвичайно Дякую що ви
сьогодні з нами хочу трошки вам
розповісти школу супергероїв і
зануритися ми вже існуємо на протязі
семи років і в нас є вісім осередків в
обласних лікарнях України з
повномасштабним російським вторгненням
категорія наших діток у нас змінилася це
страшно так казати але ми знаємо як
працювати з дітьми з онкологічними
захворюваннями віл-інфекції СНІДом але
зараз ми працюємо з дітками з вогневими
пораненнями котрі дов зараз могли
перебувати в окупації котрі втратили
своїх рідних
Ці діти зазнали не тільки фізичного і
звісно психологічного
насилля
тобто в них не тільки фізичні травми ми
і ми маємо намагаємося зробити
якнайбільше і з того що можливо скажу
вам відверто спочатку на масштабного
вторгнення наших вся команда вчителів
волонтерів вона була вся в такому
зануренні занепокоєнням ми хотіли не
якнайбільше допомогти країні в нас всіх
повернула до викладання історії
14-річної Карини котра влетіла всю
Україну котра приїхала з Маріуполя з неї
на спілкувалися ніхто але дитина сказала
я хочу готуватися до ЗНО з математики Ну
ми всі знаємо що ЗНО немає є
тест котрі його замінив А але для неї
повернення до звичайного життя до
будення Це її психологічна
відбудова і той психологічний зріз про
котрика казала пані Катерина до мене
тому що я хочу сказати державна установа
Школа супергероїв як державна установа
вона вже зареєстрована і вона буде
працювати з вересня місяця ми вас
надзвичайно чекаємо в наших рядах будь
ласка в восьми містах Київ Харків Херсон
Хмельницький Житомир Приходьте ставайте
нашими вчителями Ми сподіваємося що в
наступному році в кожній обласній
лікарні ми зможемо відкрити свій
осередок і надавати освіту друзі А якщо
є запити від дітей Ми готові долучатися
навіть там де немає осередків школи
супергероїв і навчати дітей в лікарнях
ми маємо три форми освіти це групова
індивідуальна та дистанційна ну тобто ми
зможемо підключити ваших і вас і ваших
підопічних якщо ви знаєте таких діток
будь ласка Приходьте до нас вставайте
нашими супергероями ставайте нашими
вчителями тому що ми маємо тримати цей
фронт цей освітній фронт
Я знаю що зараз Найс найбільше слухає
представників фрц викладачів
будь ласка Я вас прошу звертайте увагу
на діток котрі були в лікарнях тому що в
них можуть бути особливі освітні потреби
особливо хто довгий час звісно та Мають
бути дотримані всі процедури але
придивляйтеся може їм потрібне
допомога асистента вчителя або асистента
вихователя
будьте чуйними які ми ви є зараз
будьте такими ж неймовірними тому що ви
формуєте майбутнє України І ми вас дуже
чекаємо Я знаю що вже наш вичерпується
час я дуже дякую організаторам
міністерству освіти і науки України
пані Ольга Дякую вам за організацію і
слава Україні
Героям слава Героям слава і також я б
хотіла себе в свою чергу Міністерства і
я думаю всіх інших подякувати йому в
школі супергероїв за цю всю роботу яка
вона здійснюється тому що
діти які отримали поранення діти які
стали жертвами вони в першу чергу
потрапляють під ваш допомогу під вашого
Віку І це
безумовно і ніхто не дасть нігті Певно
що всі з учасників підтвердять що це
зрозуміють що це найскладніша категорія
дітей бо ви стоїте першими на такі як
сказати першими зустрічаючими які
здійснюють допомогу дітям і першими хто
їх повертає до життя і просто не
повертає не лише фізично до життя а й
повертає їх
емоціонально психологічно і до освіти
тому що дуже дякую вам і вашому обличчі
всім вчителям які працюють у лікарнях і
кожного дня допомагають дітям і хоті
також звернути увагу наших всіх колег
які слухають нашу область Так що справді
школи супергероїв вони відкриті для
вашої допомоги Якщо у вас є натхнення є
бажання є можливості в школах завжди
будуть вас раді бачити як викладачів як
людей які можуть е-е
забезпечити роботу гуртків забезпечити
підтримку бо діти там справді потребують
нашої уваги нашої турботи і навіть іноді
просто нашою присутності коли вони
розуміють що їм що нам всім дорослим ми
готові їх підтримати готові їх захистити
і готові бути поряд з ними для них це є
дуже важливим і окремо Дякую вам ще
розповісти за роботу всіх вчителів у
лікарні Це є дуже важливим дуже вам
дякую
Отже будемо підводити підсумок нашої
сьогоднішньої конференції в конференції
нашої сьогоднішньої нашої секції
конференції
Дуже дякуємо Ще раз всім спікерам Які
прийняли участь наголошуємо що ви можете
переглянути запис нашої нашої секції на
сайті Міністерства освіти і науки
України в YouTube каналі і на Фейсбуці
ми спробуємо поширити серед наших е-е
груп в Вайбері цей ресурсний центр
підтримки інклюзивної освіти серед
обласних ми поширимо ще раз посилання на
цю трансляцію
ви можете його також
поділитися з ними зі своїми
співробітниками з
педагогічної працівниками які працюють з
дітьми з особливими освітніми і навіть з
тими які ще не працюють з дітьми з
особливими освітніми потребами розуміємо
що кожен клас в якийсь момент може стати
інклюзивним кожна дитина в якийсь момент
дитина може потребувати підтримки в
освітньому процесі вона може вже мати
особливий скільки потреби вони можуть
бути тимчасовими Або можуть стати
постійними але в будь-якому разі
будь-який педагог має вміти знати і
розуміти як йому працювати з дитиною яка
потребує такої підтримки бо це є дуже
важливим і наша робота з вами є дуже
важливим ми ж всі розуміємо що робота
кожного педагога є важливим тому що ми
ці люди які забезпечують освіту в тій
люди які виховують і люди які
допомагають Ці діти люди які
соціалізують А але особливо важливо
робота саме тих людей які працюють над
особливостями потребами які будуть зараз
працювати з дітьми з психологічними
травмами психологічним станом тому що це
ще більш складна робота Але яка є дуже
потрібна яка дуже вагомає від якої Ці
діти не зможуть впоратися і Ці діти не
зможуть отримати якісну освіту а в
подальшому якісного жити працювати
соціалізуватися І це є безпосередньо
дуже важливим Отже Ще раз дякую всім
спікерам ще раз Нагадую що ви можете
ознайомитися з матеріалами на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки України в
YouTube каналі Міністерства освіти
України на Facebook сторінці
Міністерства освіти науки України також
дякую гостину нашим е-е
господарям Ми сьогодні проводили
трансляцію з
ірц Голосіївського району міста Києва Я
навіть тут вам хочу сказати що походила
пофотографувала тому на Фейсбуці будуть
фотографії з цього як це дуже вам дякую
Я всі думаю ви всі знайомі з
представниками це дуже дякую керівнику
пані Ірина за те що я знаю що ви теж
під'єдналася за те що нас тут радо
зустріли допомогли з трансляцією
познайомилися з цим всім що в них є
напрацьовано тому що я знаю що подібні
напрацювання подібні технології нас є в
інших версія дуже Я знаю що у вас є
спільна група Я знаю що ви ділитеся
своїми
спільною роботою дуже вам дякую за кожен
день на вашу роботу і ще раз дякую нашим
господарям нашого зустрічі сьогоднішньої
Отже до зустрічі е-е знаємо що скоро
буде перемога віримо в те що вона
наближалася як найскоріше знаємо про те
що всі наші тимчасово окуповані
території повернуться в Україну що всі
наші діти будуть з нами якщо всі наші
педагоги будуть з нами
тримаємося
Слава Україні Ми переможемо Гарного вам
сім'я і мирного неба і поменше три роки